simplify 4a squared b and this whole
quantity is being raised to the third
power now here we'll just use the
property if we have the product of
things let's say i have a times b
and i'm raising that to some power n
this is just going to be equal to a to
the n
times
b to the n and to realize why that
happens let's just try it out let's just
try it out with
some simple example if i have a times b
to the third power what is that going to
be equal to that is going to be equal to
a times b that's to the first power then
times a times b that's to the second
power times a times b that's to the
third power that's exactly what we're
literally taking this expression and
multiplying by itself three times
now we can just swap these around
because of the commutative and the
associative properties of multiplication
so if we just swap these around just
change the order that we're multiplying
we can rewrite this as a times a times a
times b times b times b we have three
a's here three b's and so this over here
is going to be a to the third and this
right over here is going to be equal to
b to the third so we have a to the third
times b to the third so it worked and so
hopefully that gives you a sense of why
this property holds now let's apply it
to the actual problem
so we have 4a squared b to the third
power that means that each of these
components in the product are going to
be raised to the third power so that so
that means it equals four to the third
power
times a squared to the third power times
b to the third power let me color code
it this third power here in magenta
that's the third power over here i'm
just raising instead of taking the
product first and then raising that to
the third power i can take each of the
terms in the product each of the each of
the numbers in the product and raise
those to the third power first and then
take the product
so that's what we're doing and let's try
to simplify this so what is 4
what is 4 to the third power 4 to the
first is 4 4 to the second is 16 and
then we want to multiply 16 times 4 so 4
to the third power which is 4 times 4
times 4 is 64.
and then we have
a squared and we are raising that to the
third power we know from the product
property of exponents that's going to be
a to the 2 times 3 power or a to the
sixth power so this is a to the 6th
power we got 6 from 2 times 3 and then
finally
we just have the b to the third power
let me do that in a different color we
just have the b to the third power and
we'll just write it over here so we
simplify this expression to 64 a to the
sixth b to the third power